how of the cast of The Big Bang Theory
been spending their days you might be
surprised to find out which two stars
have gone from physicists to super
villains affectionately known as Mima on
the show Constance Connie Tucker is the
grandmother of Sheldon Cooper a deeply
protective and loving character she was
first introduced in 2016 in the season 9
episode The me ma materialization in
which she comes to visit her grandson to
meet Amy this is her only on-screen
appearance in the show although a
younger incarnation of the character
does return in young Sheldon played by
Annie Potts
Squibb is the actor responsible for
portraying MIMA in The Big Bang Theory
prior to appearing in the series her
most famous role was probably in the
2013 film Nebraska a performance that
earned her an Academy Award nomination
for best supporting actress in recent
years she's voiced characters in Disney
animated films such as Toy Story 4 and
has continued to be a regular face on
television as well with numerous guest
appearances on shows like good girls
Melissa Missy Cooper Sheldon's sister is
another important Big Bang Theory
character who has a very limited number
of appearances in the show although
she's mentioned many times she's only
directly involved in two episodes she's
first introduced in the season 1 episode
the pork chop indeterminacy in which he
visits Sheldon but her next in-person
appearance doesn't come until the bow
tie asymmetry some 10 seasons later
before a small appearance at her
brother's wedding outside of The Big
Bang Theory actor Courtney hengler will
be familiar to fans of the Netflix
series Cobra Kai in which he plays
Karate Kid protagonist Daniel larusso's
wife Amanda she's also had recent roles
in films like Tyler Perry's romantic
comedy nobody's fool and on stage in
Productions such as 2023's Cat on a Hot
Tin Roof
I'm like
Jerry O'Connell plays Sheldon's older
brother George who doesn't make his
debut in the sitcom until season 11
first showing up in the sibling
realignment
despite making a success of his own
business Georgie expresses resentment to
the way Sheldon has treated his family
although the pair reconcile and the
character appears in the next episode
when Sheldon marries Amy
Jordy later appears in season 12 during
a webcam chat with Sheldon as they
discuss a childhood friend named Tam
having begun his career at a young age
O'Connell had his first major film role
in 1986 in the Stephen King adaptation
Stand By Me in his adult life he has had
roles in the likes of Jerry Maguire and
plays Stephen Birch in billions since
2021 O'Connell has also been one of the
permanent co-hosts of the CBS daytime
show The Talk having replaced Sharon
Osborne I'd like to
good time Sarah Gilbert's Leslie Winkle
is a regular character through the early
seasons of The Big Bang Theory appearing
for the first time in season 1 episode
3. she appears throughout the second and
third Seasons before largely
disappearing from the show a scientist
at Caltech she works with Leonard and
dates both him and Howard for short
periods of time she can often be seen
using lab equipment to cook her food and
is friendly toward basically everyone
except for Sheldon Gilbert is most
famous as a regular on both Roseanne and
its more recent spin-off the Connors
playing Darlene Connor Healy her
performance across the two shows has
earned her several Primetime Emmy Award
nominations she was one of the hosts of
the talk for nearly a decade beginning
in 2010 and had a role in the 2023
comedy movie 80 for Brady
Mary Cooper played by Laurie Metcalf in
The Big Bang Theory is Sheldon's mother
in total Mary appears in 14 episodes of
the show making her first appearance in
the fourth ever episode despite being a
loving and caring mother she is
something of a religious fanatic and can
be bigoted an experienced actor and
comedian Metcalf has been nominated for
a plethora of awards throughout her
career including Primetime Emmy Awards
and an Academy Award for her role in
ladybird in 2017. perhaps best known for
her performance as Jackie Harris in
Roseanne she later reprized the part for
the spin-off series The Connors
2022 Metcalf had an emmy-winning guest
role in two episodes of hacks and she
also voices Andy's mom in the Toy Story
franchise
Laura Spencer's Emily Sweeney first
appears in the Friendship turbulence as
a woman who contacts Raj through an
online dating site over the course of
the next few seasons she appears in a
total of 17 episodes dating Raj and then
Gary a self-confessed fan of horror
films she has a dark sense of humor and
prefers the original gruesome fairy
tales to the modern family-friendly
Disney movies
Spencer first gained Fame after
appearing in 34 episodes of the web
series the Lizzie Bennett Diaries she
became a regular on television during
her tenure on The Big Bang Theory as she
simultaneously portrayed intern Jessica
Warren on Bones her work has seemingly
been limited over the last few years
with the actor only appearing in a
single episode of reservation dogs and
the disaster film 13 minutes in 2021
Stuart Bloom played by actor Kevin
Sussman is a major character in The Big
Bang Theory and a constant presence
starting from season two he dates both
Penny and Amy at different points and is
the owner of the comic Center of
Pasadena making him a friend to Sheldon
and the rest of the main group
Sussman has had a busy few years since
the Big Bang Theory came to an end he
had a two-episode roll on the Breaking
Bad spin-off Better Call Saul playing a
victim of one of the protagonist's scams
that same year in 2022 he also appeared
in the Dropout playing a researcher at
the pharmaceutical company theranos
the actor also appeared in a couple
episodes of call me Kat and will play
Walter in the upcoming Apple TV Plus
drama series lessons in chemistry early
on in The Big Bang Theory it appeared as
if Sheldon would never find love but
then came Amy Farrah Fowler played by
mayam Bialik his match in almost every
sense a neurobiologist she makes her
debut in the lunar excitation in season
3 and quickly becomes irregular
appearing in more than 200 episodes of
the show Amy has a strong relationship
with Sheldon from the very beginning and
the pair eventually married during the
season 11 finale
Bialik who has a PHD in Neuroscience in
real life was nominated for a series of
awards for her performance on the show
and has been in high demand since
I actually was trained in calculus for
several years yeah I'm a neuroscientist
so you may not have known that she stars
in the fox sitcom call me cat and
following the death of Alex Trebek
Bialik was announced as one of the new
permanent hosts for the popular game
show Jeopardy following a temporary
stint behind the lectern
she also hosts her own podcast
myumbiolics breakdown every Tuesday in
which she discusses Mental Health
Bernadette is another main character
from The Big Bang Theory who comes in a
bit later on played by Melissa Roush she
makes her first appearance in the season
3 episode the creepy candy coding
corollary and quickly begins a
relationship with Howard Wolowitz she
eventually achieves a PhD and starts a
family with Howard Roush made her
breakthrough with the Big Bang Theory
but she has continued to find success
since the show ended her most notable
role has been in the NBC sitcom Revival
Night Court where she plays judge Abby
Stone she has also voiced a number of
characters in various films and
television series ranging from Harley
Quinn in Batman and Harley Quinn dubo's
mom Beth in firebutts Raj is one of the
five primary characters who are present
from the very beginning of The Big Bang
Theory played by Kunal Nair he's
Howard's best friend and works at
Caltech as an astrophysicist Raj often
finds himself physically incapable of
speaking to women which causes him to
struggle in establishing meaningful
relationships except with Howard despite
the actor's good looks Kunal I thought
was the most handsome man
after the end of The Big Bang Theory
Nair landed a number of roles he's
provided the voice of guy diamond in the
trolls franchise since 2016 and had a
role in Think Like a dog in 2020. he's
set to appear in the upcoming Netflix
film Spaceman ever since being announced
as part of the cast in 2021 Nair also
starred in the 2022 film The Story life
of AJ fickory as well as the Apple TV
plus series suspicion
played by Johnny Galecki Leonard is one
of the central characters of The Big
Bang Theory present in every single
episode of the show he's Sheldon's
colleague best friend and roommate
despite being a geek Leonard also
demonstrates the most knowledge of
social cues and rarely struggles to fit
in with more ordinary company
throughout the run of the series he has
a rocky relationship with Penny although
the two do eventually marry Galecki
earned numerous accolades including a
Primetime Emmy Award nomination for his
performance at the Big Bang Theory
however he's also known for his work on
the sitcom Roseanne and its spin-off the
Connors he hasn't done much on screen
lately outside of his appearances in the
Connors but he has worked behind the
scenes as an executive producer on shows
such as living biblically among others
Sheldon Cooper was arguably the most
popular character from The Big Bang
Theory as evidenced by the fact that
actor Jim Parsons won numerous Awards
and the character got his own spin-off
show Sheldon lives with Leonard and is
an unashamed intelligent nerd who
consistently shows a lack of
understanding of basic human traits like
humor and empathy he also struggles in
his relationships until he meets Amy
Farrah Fowler who he eventually marries
in season 11.
fans of The Big Bang Theory will know
that Parsons has continued to be a part
of the fictional universe as the
narrator of the show Young Sheldon
outside of his role as Sheldon the actor
has appeared in the miniseries Hollywood
as talent agent Henry Wilson the 2022
romantic drama spoiler alert alongside
Ben Aldridge and 2020's the boys in the
band he's also worked as an executive
producer on a number of shows including
his former co-star Mayim bialix call me
cat
penny is the sole female main character
at the start of The Big Bang Theory
played by Kaley Cuoco Penny also stands
out because she doesn't share the same
genius level intellect as the four other
original leads although she makes up for
this with a more sophisticated emotional
intelligence that ensures she's far more
outgoing and empathetic by the end of
the series she marries Leonard and the
two move in together Cuoco has worked in
a number of critically acclaimed series
since the conclusion of The Big Bang
Theory in 2017 she founded yes Norman
Productions through which she's produced
and starred in the acclaimed HBO Max
series the flight attendant and Harley
Quinn she has several other projects
currently in the works at yes Norman
including an upcoming film about the
life of Doris Day
although he is part of the main group of
characters on The Big Bang Theory Howard
is notable for the fact that he's
actually an aerospace engineer rather
than a scientist best friends with Raj
he studied at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology and works at
Caltech with the rest of the group a fan
of comic books and geek culture in
general Howard has a collection of
novelty belt buckles and little luck
with women until he begins dating
Bernadette like many of his former
co-stars Simon hillberg has also had
roles in several other projects in the
last few years the actor had a
supporting role in the musical film
Annette and starred in as they made us a
movie written and directed by Mayim
Bialik Helberg has also had Parts in
Space Oddity and Ryan Johnson's crime
drama series poker face as well as
voicing the squirrel in the up spin-off
series Doug days
foreign
[Music]